it's a time of gift giving and charity
unfortunately and this is sad the
holidays also bring out a lot of
dishonest people who take advantage of
others generosity well folks don't you
worry our own Andy Richter is on the
case he's gonna warn us he's going to
warn us about some of these ripoffs in a
segment called Andy's holiday scam watch
[Applause]
Thank You Conan this first one's called
the letter trick your children start
writing letters to Santa Claus asking
for things like
Gameboys and hoverboards well you don't
want to disappoint them
so you buy those things Santa gets all
the credit and you're out 600 bucks
I need up
that's not really a scam this next scam
is called The Parent Trap you're
visiting your parents on Christmas Eve
and they say let's go to midnight mass
you're not much of a believer but okay
if only to get out of there overheated
house thing is you've been sneaking
shots of bourbon in the guest bathroom
since 8:30 so now you're drunk in church
and the choir starts singing and the
spirit of Christmas fills you up when
the collection plate comes around you
drop your whole wad of cash in there the
final score is baby Jesus two hundred
dollars and you nothing
and II again that's not a scam I mean
are there any actual scams you want to
warn us about oh there sure are Conan
this one's called the secret scam tuck
you decide to do Secret Santa at the
office the rules clearly state the most
you can spend is $25 and you pull Sherri
Hanson's name out of the Hat
Sherri works in human resources you
don't know anything about her so you
forget all about Secret Santa until the
last day then it's panic time you have
to ask your assistant
what Sherri likes and she says Lladro
figurines whatever-the-hell yatra
figurines are so you say fine go to
Macy's get me the cheapest one well it
turns out the cheapest Lladro is a
hundred and ten bucks $25 limit my ass
what if I told a little bit buyers
No all right no I'm with you now that
one is a scam I got sherry last year I
had to buy her the same thing those
things are really expensive she's done
it to everyone we're on to you sherry in
human resources
sure in human resources
why does she why does she sit right near
the stage I don't understand by her desk
is there hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please